[موسيقى]
الساري الهندي الحريري
هو رمز للمكانة وخصوصًا أنه
يُستخدم وقت الزواج
ولتقديم الهدايا
[موسيقى]
إذا كنت تفكر في الحرير ، فأنت تصور
منتجًا فاخرًا
لا ترغب في التفكير فيه بشأن هذا
المنتج
كنتيجة لسخرة شخص ما
[الموسيقى]
العظام والعمل هو أكبر
شكل من أشكال العبودية الحديثة في عالم اليوم ، فإن
شيئًا يبدو أنه جميل جدًا
يكلف الناس
حريتهم وهذا أمر صادم
[موسيقى]
مؤخرًا وجدنا أمًا وابنتها
كانتا تعملان في  إنتاج الحرير
وكانوا في ظروف عبودية ،
كانت الأم تعمل كعاملة جسدية
لمدة
ثماني إلى تسع سنوات ، وقد اقترضت
100000 روبية الآن ، وقد أصبح الآن 200000
روبية
بسبب الديون التي
أخذوها هم محاصرون
في العمل مع شخص ما لتسديد
ما تفعله هنا في عملك ،
ما الذي تفعله
في المصنع ، كم من الوقت
تعمل في صناعة الحرير ،
بدأت هذا العمل منذ ثلاث سنوات ونحن
نعمل فيه  هذا
المصنع 11 ساعة في اليوم ونحصل على
روبية فقط. ما الذي تفعله بالضبط في
المصنع ، ما
نوع العمل الذي يجب أن نقوم به لغلي
الطهي وعلينا إزالة الخيط
والحرير
يصنع منه الماء البخاري الذي سيأتي إلى
حيث  هذه
رائحة كريهة جدًا
ونحن أيضًا بدأت أيدينا تنزف ،
ما أخاف منه أنا خائف من
مالكنا
لأنه أعطانا المنزل لنعيش
فيه حيث يجب أن نذهب لا يمكننا الذهاب إلى أي مكان
لذلك نخشى أن نظهر إخفاقاتنا
ولا نعرف ما الذي سيفعله
معنا ، لذا بعد التاريخ هذا الفيديو
[موسيقى]
من الصعب جدًا إقناع
العمال المستعبدين
لأنهم يشعرون أنهم
مدينون للسادة أو أصحاب العقارات
الذين ساعدوا  لهم في ساعة
حاجتهم ،
هاتان المرأتان خائفتان جدًا
من الشخص
الذي يدفعان الموت
للعمل في مصنعه
، كانت الفتاة ذكية جدًا تتحدث
الإنجليزية الجميلة
وهي تعمل في مصنع حرير مما
يعني أنها تتعامل مع الماء الساخن
مع ضجيج هائل
مع بيت ، كانت تصرخ في
وجهها ، قيل لها إنها إذا لم
تتبع جميع تعليمات مالكها
، فسوف يتم اغتصابها ، لقد شعرت بالرعب حقًا ، لقد
شعرت بالأسف الشديد عليها ،
لماذا قررت تسجيل
هذا المعلم  قالت الزوجة قم بالعمل
بشكل صحيح ،
فعندما جاء الزوج بدأت
بالصراخ
، جاء وقال لوالدتي إذا كنت
لن تسدد المال ، فأين
الرجل الذي أشرت إليه عليك أن
تذهب وتنام مع هذا الرجل ،
كل من الأم والأم.  يتم التعامل مع الابنة
بشكل سيء للغاية
لشيء واحد عليهم العمل
لساعات طويلة جدًا
، يذهبون في الصباح الباكر حوالي الساعة السادسة
صباحًا ويمكنهم العودة فقط في الساعة 5:30 أو 6
مساءً
وفي 11 إلى 12 ساعة يحصلون عليها
لا يكاد يحصل كل منهم على ثلاثة دولارات في
اليوم
، فهو فقط لسداد القرض أو إذا لم يتمكنوا من
السداد ، يريدهم أن يمارسوا الدعارة لأنفسهم ،
لقد حددنا عددًا من
الأشخاص المقيدين ،
لكن الغالبية منهم لا يريدون
الخروج  ال  open لقد
أسست jivika
لأنني صادفت شر العمل الاستعبادي
مع 40 عاملاً مستعبداً في
قرية واحدة من عام 1988
حتى عام 1990 ، قمت بجمع البيانات من
حوالي 300
قرية لم ترغب الأم والابنة
في التعريف بأنفسهم
ما لم يقدموا  الأوراق
وتلقي المعلومات التي تفيد بإعفائهم
من الديون ،
فهم يخشون أن يأتي المالك في
أي وقت ،
لذلك لا يريدون الاستفادة
من المالك لدعم أنفسهم ،
كما أنهم يشعرون
أنهم ملزمون بالوفاء
بوعدهم.  سيقومون
بالسداد ويعتقدون أنه من واجبهم السداد ،
لكنهم لا
يحسبون حقًا أنه يستغلهم حقًا
وأنه بالنسبة لعدد السنوات التي
عمل فيها ، كان سيسدد
دفعة القرض التي
أخذها عدة مرات
لأنه لا يرى ذلك بسهولة باعتباره
استغلالًا
بمجرد أن تجد السلطة
أن الشخص عامل بالسخرة ،
فعليه أن يتخذ إجراءً لتحرير الشخص
والخطوة الأولى في تحريره.  هو تقديم
شهادة إغاثة
وبمجرد استلام عامل الحدود شهادة يومية ،
يصبح ذلك مصدر
استحقاق يتطلب جهدًا هائلًا منا
لجعل المسؤولين يفعلون ما
يفترض بهم القيام به ، حيث
ينص القانون الهندي بوضوح شديد على
أنه  عامل مقيد ، يحق للشخص
الذهاب إلى
الضابط وبعد تقديم الورقة
للمطالبة باستعادة الحرية
ولكن الحقيقة هي أن هؤلاء الأشخاص
عادة ما يكافحون من أجل تقديم
هذا الأمر معقد للغاية ، ومن
المخيف التحدث إلى
الضابط
ولكن هاتين السيدتين ربما بسبب
من شجاعة الابنة
، كانوا مستعدين لتقديم أوراقهم ، لكن بشرط
أن يكونوا قد قدموا أوراقًا يجب ألا
يتم الكشف عنها للمالك حتى يتم
إطلاق سراحهم ،
فهم يخشون أنه إذا علم أصحاب المصنع
أنهم قدموا أوراقًا ، فسيخشون ذلك.
يتم طردهم من ذلك المنزل
ولن يكون لديهم أي مكان
للعيش فيه
ولكنهم خائفون جدًا من أننا ذهبنا إلى
المكتب الذي كنا بحاجة إلى الانتظار
في طابور طويل  كانت المرة الأولى التي
يواجهون فيها شخصًا يمثل
الحكومة ،
لذا من الواضح أنهم كانوا متوترين بعد
دخولنا المكتب ، التقينا بالمسؤول ،
وشرحنا المواقف
التي تواجهها هؤلاء النساء
ومن الواضح أننا سمعنا أن ما
يحدث لهن
غير قانوني لجميع المواطنين الهنود.
لديك الحق في أن تكون حرة
والعمل المقيد ممنوع يمكننا
استدعاء العمال المستعبدين في الصباح
والمساء ، نعم يمكننا الاتصال
بالمالكين بعد المحادثة
سلمنا الأوراق التي تم تقديمها من
قبل وسمعنا أنه من المفترض
أن يأتي الرد قريبًا  الرد عادة لا يكون
سريعًا في
كثير من الأحيان يحتاج الناس إلى الانتظار
سنوات حتى يتلقوا إجابة إيجابية
تخبرهم بأنهم أحرار
وأنه يمكن دعمهم من قبل
الحكومة
من أجل أن يكونوا مستدامين مرة أخرى
نهج كيران معقد حقًا
وهذا أمر رائع  ليرى
أنه يدرك أن هذه العملية
لتحرير شخص ما معقدة حقًا
مع العلم أنه يدعم
الفيكتوري  ملي من
العمل الغزير والعملية برمتها
من فهم
نوع الموقف الذي يواجهونه
فيما يتعلق بما يجب عليهم فعله مع الموقف وكيفية
استعادة حريتهم
علاوة على كيفية عيش حياتهم لاحقًا
بعد
أن يكونوا رائعين مجانًا
[موسيقى]
[  موسيقى]
أنت